[Music]
uh
in this film
we need shrink shriek has the ability to
suck up sound and use it as a weapon
she can be really dangerous they're
sending me to a place where there are
others like me so she's been kept in a
box at ravencroft for 25 years
she only cares about one human being and
that's cletus
she's twisted like cletus happy days
they'll do anything to come back
together
together they're so much fun and
incredibly terrifying
eddie is venom with you
you bet your ass
this thursday
the universe
needs phenomena you know how much i love
an underdog lucky me
welcome back everyone this is my new
venom let there be carnage video they
released a couple of new scenes and
there's also this really really
hilarious topher grace venom post that
he made recently trolling people about
spiderman no way home with all the tobey
maguire stuff coming back from his
movies if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything i will be doing full post
credit scene videos easter egg videos
breakdowns for the entire movie once it
comes out later this week i also think
i'm allowed to post my review by
wednesday so if i'm able to get that
video out fast enough then i will post a
review for the movie i'll start with the
new footage here then i'll talk about
the funny topher grace spider-man no way
home venom stuff at the end of the video
but they start with the prison break
scene of carnage fully formed now
emerging from cletus cassidy there was
an earlier scene that i posted last week
that explains how he gets the carnage
symbiote so i'll link that below in the
description it's a small change from the
carnage origin story in the comics so in
the original spider-man comics
spider-man winds up defeating venom
during one of their fights then eddie
brock gets sent to prison and his
cellmate winds up being cletus cassidy
so eventually the venom symbiote comes
to rescue eddie and when they bust out
the venom symbiote spawns and then that
spawn finds cletus cassidy in bonds with
him becoming carnage then they break out
a prison and go on a killing spree and
spider-man has to find out what's going
on and then stop them eventually carnage
becomes so powerful that spider-man and
venom have to put their differences
aside to team up during the maximum
carnage storyline to take carnage down
we know there's a big spider-man venom
crossover movie that's coming up they've
been hyping up between tom hardy and tom
hall and spider-man so it seems logical
that they would riff on that kind of
story for their big crossover movie the
difference during venom let there be
carnage is that cletus winds up biting
eddie and ingests some of his blood and
some of the symbiote then once that
bonds with cletus cassidy's body that
winds up evolving into a wholly
different symbiote the carnage symbiote
so as they're executing him here this
scene is meant to be another parallel
for that scene of eddie brock inside the
medical scanner where the venom symbiote
starts freaking out just bursting out of
his body only this time for the carnage
origin story they're playing it like a
death and rebirth scene like cletus
cassidy is dying they're injecting him
with all these lethal chemicals and you
can see him slowly dying so cletus dies
briefly so that he can be reborn as
carnage and there is a big difference in
the way the carnage symbiote bonds with
cletus cassidy from the way normal
symbiotes like the venom symbiote bonds
with eddie brock or other hosts like
flash thompson agent venom or even toxin
or antivenom or the primal symbiote
carnage is different because it's not
just a regular symbiote that enters
cletus's body and forms a partnership
with him the way that venom and eddie
brock are partners or the way bruce
banner and the hulk are partners also
reference the hulk again in a second too
when i talk about the other footage
because a lot of what's going on with
venom during the movie and eddie brock
is similar to what was going on between
banner and the hulk during avengers
infinity war and avengers end game but
no we're not going to get professor
venom or anything like that anytime soon
the difference with carnage is that the
carnage symbiote and cletus are bonded
at the cellular level so much that
neither one of them cletus nor the
carnage symbiote knows where one of them
begins and the other one ends they think
of themselves truly as a single being
thus the phrase we are carnage now that
is venom's catchphrase too he says it
all the time we are venom but it's meant
to be totally different the way carnage
uses that phrase eddie brock and venom
agree to be bros and work together but
there's still two distinct personalities
two distinct minds eddie has his own
wants and desires and so does the venom
symbiote carnage is more like a singular
mind a single desire for just complete
destruction utter chaos and that's one
of the reasons why he starts out
initially being so much more powerful
than venom because there's no limits
with him he just a hundred percent all
the time whereas with venom during the
movie as andy circus tells it in that
clip eddie and venom are the odd couple
fighting constantly unable to live
together peacefully but also they can't
stand to be a part in the movie eddie is
supposed to be just as selfish and
self-serving as comic book eddie brock
like imagine spider-man if he were a
total and only ever really
thought of himself oh wait no you don't
have to imagine it because they actually
did that during a movie everyone cue the
emo bully parker dance montage
look at little goblin jr
gonna cry i cannot wait to see how they
handle tom hall and spider-man once he
gets the symbiote i'm not expecting any
dance montages or anything but don't be
surprised if they save that twist for
the venom spiderman crossover movie that
all the sony and marvel people have been
hyping up recently consequently that
crossover is also probably when they'll
finally give the venom symbiote the big
spiderman symbol on its chest from the
comics for those of you that have felt
like that's been missing for the past
couple of years since the first venom
movie most of carnage's powers and
abilities are pretty much what you see
from him in the comics he uses his
symbio powers to form hard edge weapons
and projectiles if you've ever wondered
if it's possible for him to run out of
ammo so to speak like if his weapons are
made of himself extensions of the
carnage symbiote itself and he throws
them at people or at venom when they're
fighting does that mean that carnage
loses mass and gets weaker the more he
does that the technical answer to that
is yes kind of but the symbiotes can
replace their mass not just carnage
venom can do this too any of the
symbiotes can by just consuming more
matter more nutrition eating people
eating food usually though it's the
first one eating people the symbios
repair their own tissues the same way
that the human body consumes nutrition
and converts that to energy powering
your body's ability to repair itself
ages of the symbiotes do that way way
faster so if carnage were in the middle
of a fight and he needed a reload so to
speak all he'd have to do would be just
eating a couple people the symbiotes can
also make themselves appear or get even
bigger if they want to as well they just
need to consume way more matter but
usually they're just depicted as being
slightly larger than the people that
they're bonded to more for practical
reasons like eddie brock is only five
nine because tom hardy is five nine but
when the venom symbiote comes out he's
more like seven or eight feet tall it's
just like banner and the hulk banner is
average height kind of scrawny the hulk
is about eight feet tall in his base
form but still built like a tree trunk
also talking more about the hulk
references in avengers infinity war the
whole reason the russos explained they
did hook and banner this way with hulk
eventually refusing to come out isn't
just because he lost the fight to thanos
it was more about him hating banner and
that was what all the dialogue about him
only wanting hulk for fighting was meant
to be hulk basically felt like banner
was selfish and only used him when it
was convenient for banner and hulk had
his own dreams and desires like he
wanted to be free just like everyone
else they had a huge deleted scene
during the final battle in avengers
infinity war where they were going to
watch hulk and banner come to the
agreement and form professor hulk but
they said that they opted to save that
reveal for vendor's endgame i posted the
whole avengers infinity war hulk deleted
scene on my channel a couple years ago
so i'll add a link for that in the
description below but in this movie
venom and eddie have their own version
of that kind of a scene where they have
to both come together finally so they
can be even more powerful we've seen
some of that in the trailer footage it
takes place in the church here where
they have their big venom versus carnage
battle and he's like you need to come
out right now i will let you eat
everybody also this being at a church is
a huge easter egg for a number of
different spider-man stories and carnage
stories anytime venom is in a church it
reminds you of the classic venom origin
story they did a version of that with
the tobey maguire spider-man 3 movie but
also referencing toby maguire spider-man
3 the topher grace version of venom
recently topher grace did a reddit ama
for something completely unrelated and
of course during that someone asked him
are you going to be in spiderman no way
home because of all the tobey maguire
spiderman characters that are coming
back during that like doctor octopus and
the tobey maguire cameo scene that we're
all expecting of course and i think
we're all in agreement that there is no
way that topher grace is going to show
up during spider-man no way home like we
all just innately understand that
they're not going to bring that
character back but this was topher
grace's way of giving the funniest troll
answer that you've ever heard so this is
actually toe for grace answering this
kid saying please keep it between us but
yes i'm in it the plot starts with peter
parker tom holland bummed that everyone
knows his identity and then some crazy
happens with doctor strange and
doctor octopus alfred molina comes into
his dimension then electro and the green
goblin hop out of one of those energy
circles i love the way he calls it
energy circles like he's trying to be
extra funny about it and they're like
it's spider stomp in time then tom hardy
and i pop out and battle each other and
i win obviously like it's not even a
fight i just kick his ass immediately
not to give too much away but there are
also some actors from the original 70s
spider-man show aquaman batman affleck
not keaton i love the way he included
that little detail and thanks to disney
han solo's ghost from rise of skywalker
and that eve robot from wally again
please keep this between us that is
probably one of the best troll answers
that i've ever seen an actor give about
them being questioned as to whether or
not they're in a giant movie but the
venom movie is coming out later this
week my post credit scene video will
probably post thursday night or friday
morning and then i'll do a full
breakdown easter eggs video make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of that my full
marvel what if episode 8 video is also
going to post wednesday too so this is a
lot of big marvel stuff happening this
week everyone click here for my brand
new marvel eternals trailer video all
about the celestials and click here to
learn all about the infinity gauntlet
version of ultron from marvel's what if
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]